That's it man we're just gonna die so
let's like let's have some fun before we
go out Brad Pitt definitely had some fun
in 2022. right right the actors here was
packed from big movie premieres
I gotta get off this train
to fun fashion moments
dabbling in the art world is still about
self uh reflection and Beyond the man
was booked and busy
12 months starting with this GQ spread
inside the mag fans got a glimpse into
the actor's journey through sobriety and
his current approach to his career quote
I consider myself on my last leg this
last semester or trimester what is this
section going to be and how do I want to
design that he's doing okay for himself
now we don't think Brad's hanging up his
acting hat anytime soon but if he does
we'll be sad to say goodbye to his bold
style statements on the red carpet I
didn't think I had any more firsts than
me but talking to Brad Pitt about
fashion is a first you've been giving us
all the looks the bullet train press
tour was full of fun Fashions and we
mean fool
get off the train
no
you stab me
nurse.com
comedy action this is like one David
Leach and I the director we always talk
about Jackie Chan how much we love
Jackie Chan he's like you know he's just
our Charlie Chaplin he's uh he's just so
underrated and it's so amazing the stuff
that he's pulled off so to do something
in that kind of vein with the comedy
infused into the fights I'd never done
before and it was really good fun and if
you're wondering what Brad's like on set
well it sounds pretty dreamy I mean he's
so amazingly normal and it's so
wonderful because I was overwhelmed and
a little intimidated when I first came
onto this project and Brad is such a big
cheerleader for everybody it's just
really it was wild to be like wow what a
what a nice freaking normal guy before
bullet train there was the lost city and
Brad's scene stealing Cameo apparently
payback for Sandra Bullock's Cameo and
another action adventure
[Applause]
foreign
we just keep doing each other favors and
we don't really know each other for some
reason he asked you know for help I show
up I ask for help he shows up and maybe
mutual respect Club I don't know and
Brad closed out the year with this
star-studded flick Damien chazelle's
Babylon when I first moved to LA Signs
and all the doors said no actors or dogs
allowed I changed that there are also
some crazy scenes there's the opening
party you're like whoa whoa whoa what
party scene is almost 30 minutes I think
and Margo snuck in a kiss you weren't
supposed she wasn't supposed to kiss you
and she kissed you no oh God there's
always room for like uh
um I guess character interpretation and
and believe me that's the tamest thing
she does in this in this she is on fire
on this she is it's the it's the best
I've ever seen her how was it working
with Brad it's brilliant this is
technically the third film we've
appeared in together and we've never
acted together until this film so that
was a wonderful gift it was just great
and he's so he's so wonderful I mean
he's just
watching Brad Pitt the biggest movie
star played the biggest movie star
there's something like just inherently
fun about that but then he just gives it
so much dimension off-screen Brad
expanded his Empire with a new skincare
line and explored a little sculpting on
the side for me it was born out of
ownership of of a really what I call a
radical inventory of self getting really
brutally honest
with me and where we're taking account
of
those I may have hurt or and those I you
know in moments I've just gotten wrong
it was lockdown you know we were all
like what do we do with ourselves what
do we do with our hands what do we do
with our lives and I just picked up a
couple of arts and crafts the guy does
it all he's even in the fashion Biz now
launching a brand of shirts called God's
true cashmere Brad promoted a line with
goop which just so happens to be run by
his ex Gwyneth Paltrow when we first
broke up we weren't friends for a while
and then we sort of found our way back
um probably about I don't know 18 or 19
years ago something like that and then
just kind of stayed in touch over the
years and I adore him the two through a
few friendly words back and forth Brad
admitting at the end of their chat quote
it's lovely to have you as a friend now
and I do love you he's an amazing person
and he's a great entrepreneur and such a
creative been such a good person I
really I love him I'm a big fan as for
what gwenit's current husband Brad
falcheck thinks of her friendship with
Brad P my husband is probably like the
least judgmental
most secure man and in our relationship
so he
I think he he totally respects and
probably one of the things that he likes
about me is that I believe in conscious
uncoupling so even though sometimes it
can be
uncomfortable I think it's nice to work
through it and reconnect with the value
that that person brought to your life
when it's not the only one showing love
to the star check out this moment of
Martha Stewart totally gushing over the
actor during a visit to The Tonight Show
I've been sort of fascinated with this
very handsome young boy on Instagram
it's called Brad Pitt
[Applause]
and and I I just I just sort of melt
when I look at those pictures I mean he
is so cute
really for real you oh I mean check it
out
[Laughter]
Brad's long been known for his good
looks but this year he spread the wealth
when it comes to compliments who are the
most handsome men in the world if I was
going to name someone present well I
gotta name that George Clooney because
why not
because usually I'm always taking him
out and he's always taking me out and
this time I'm going to go the other way
just this once George that one's for you
yes it's fine it's time yeah it's time
he finally admitted that that I'm the
guy I agree so what's next for Mr Pitt
that we don't know but we wouldn't be
mad at a little stint in music Brad's
band mates or co-stars already have a
name picked out we like to call
ourselves a band the band all right we
have a whole band name and everything
the name of the band is yeah yeah
um naked below the line
this is all Brad's doing and I think
that our album is called No harness I
have no idea but like I have no idea
please don't let I have no idea that's
right we just wear shirts
and Joey's gonna be our front person
okay that's what I was gonna say Joey's
the front man doo-wopping in the back oh
oh our Brad's been carrying a guitar a
case around there's no guitar in it it's
because dirty laundry in it but he
carries the guitar case everywhere we go
that is real
but we don't know how good he is yet
he's also our manager so you got to like
you know and he rose with an iron fist
oh now they they demoted me to manager
that was rotten bastards
[Music]